[Music]
we will try over say everything open
Winfrey is an icon she's a legend I love
her she's like the unti of a thousand
generations one time Oprah
tweeted at me and I lost my [ __ ]
one thing about Oprah she is the most
influential person probably on the
planet I'm ready to try this I'm not to
get bliss oh oh my god they are so soft
I don't know if they don't fit I feel
like my legs are fatter than this oh my
god like I don't even deserve me
Wow teddy bears butthole it feels like
cloud oh my gosh they have this gripping
so late you can walk around home I need
this in my life
I think this is something when you have
a glass of wine and you want to watch
scandal and you're not trying to deal
with these hoes they're great but it's
kind of basic for Oprah out of five
Oprah's definitely foreign half Oprah's
out of five Oprah's I'd give this a
three now bring on the next thing Tok
Tok Tok Tok uh
Thomas chef top taco
it's a hand cream it looks very like
traditional like it looks like wallpaper
no so good well so uh oh [ __ ] this
smells like a rich people wow this is a
great lotion blowing honestly my hands
feel like a baby spot it's very shimmery
it is like do you see that that glow
listen melanin muffin I give this 5
Oprah's why smell like rich person
I'll give it a 3.5
[Music]
oh it looks exquisite and like very rich
like Oprah I like how in the packaging
it says good for your body good for your
soul opening those things that are good
for your soul
soulful Sundays okay it's a booklet of
chocolate like you eat it and it makes
you want to read and get smart listen
you open up one package there's another
package smell it okay when I took a bite
out of this this is great yeah this is
um is there like a cheesy aspect to it
just because the olive oil is mixed in
oh I don't really like the paint Oprah
girl what you doing eating there who'd
you buy this for who loves me myself I'm
not to read it silence I'll Oprah's
zero Oprah's
[Music]
this is a lie I'm actually very shook
chicken this is a sorbet maker sore bit
we have a winner
frozen dessert is my thing this is so
cool this is like why I'm glad I live in
the 21st century
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's just like pretty to watch they're
really good and I work for tasty too so
like I know the team oh babe hey I mean
it's the same consistency as my food
processor my food processor is more
versatile serving overs on a farm
Oprah's five in like six million seven
eight nine okay you did Wow with this
one this is an important age I think it
makes it look big slice oh my god this
cake better give me a reason not to go
to Carvel or Cold Stone Creamery like
beakers diabetes or something you better
give me your hair ties is really good
and moist the layers are delicious I'm
not gonna be dramatic this well why is
this honestly the best red velvet cake
I've ever had in my entire life
that's some good icing I think this is
one of the best red velvet cakes I've
ever had don't know cake just tastes
like cake to me 100 over I'm gonna get
this 5l press it's so freaking good well
what was 5/7 and five girls Oprah just
gave me a good list of things to get my
siblings so then I can use them I
respect Oprah's choices I probably
wouldn't buy these things on my own I
would yeah I like my life has just been
transformed I'm tired of this low-class
listen I'm a queen
[Music]
it's your birthday
yeah